The answer that I'm looking for is the last one.
But let's go through the other ones. Could we avoid
a cache stampede by replicating a database? Yeah in theory.
it, but, but, it's, it's not a very good solution
because as we said there's a, there's a cost to
maintaining multiple machines. To running database queries It's, it's probably
not the right approach. But, it could work if you
had enough databases to handle all of the reading you're doing.
Only allow one req, web request at a time. Now this could
kind of sort of work but it means, you know, when a request
comes, you, you basically queue up all of the simultaneous requests that
you're receiving so that only one person is, only one person is hitting
the database at a time. This could also work in theory but
then you've gotta queue up these users somewhere and it slows down your
site and. It's generally, probably going to be fairly painful. Only allow one
database request at a time. This is similar to what I just mentioned.
We'd have to basically have all these requests basically block, or
wait on, on one request that's actually updated in the cache.
For doing the query that sort of thing. You can either
blo, do it in your web application, which, which would be
tricky. Or you can have some sort of lock in your
database. Either way. It's, it's, it's not going to work out as,
as well as you would like. And finally, you know, we,
just don't clear the cache. instead, overwrite the cache with new data.
So there's never this in-between time, between when we write to the
database and when we read from it again, where the cache is empty.
Make sure the cache is always, always full or, or warm. You know,
basically, we refer to a, a, a cache hit as, you know, it's
hit a, it's hit a hot cache or a warm cache. That means
the data is already in there. And this is a very simple approach,
and this is what we'll go with. Let's go ahead and implement this
in AsciiChan. Okay, so, here we are in our AsciiChan code. This is
our line where we clear the cache. We don't want to do this
anymore. Instead, we want the cache to just go ahead and update when
we submit a new, a new piece of art. We're in our post
function for set creating art. So the way I want to do it here,
is I'm going to make a function, I'm going to make this function top_arts
take a parameter called Update. And what this parameter is going to signify is
that, if update is false, it's going to behave normally. But if update is
true, we're going to update the cache, we're never going to read from the cache
if update is true. So, I'm going to use that parameter here, if not update, so
basically if update is false and the key is in the CACHE, return the
CACHE, otherwise run the query. So basically if we set update to true, we'll
always run the query. And then what we can do
is we can go down, we don't need to change the
reading, cause this basically says update false. We don't want to
update the CACHE. Every time we don't want to force that update,
we want to go down here instead of calling CACHE clear, we want to
say top_arts true. This going to rerun the query and update the cache,
so that means the user who does the submitting, triggers the re-running
of the front page query. And any users who are reading at
the same time, who are loading the front page at the same,
won't ever hit the database. That means a page view will never
hit the database. That's a very good quality to have. Let's go
ahead, and make sure things still work. So, I reload the page,
everything still works. So I look at the terminal. We see
that there was a, a DB query that we just ran.
Reload the page again. We see that there's no database query.
Now let's go ahead, and submit a, a new piece of art.
Okay, I'm going to submit a new piece of art. This is
of the, the linux penguin tux. Now, when I submit this, what's
happening is we're inserting the new piece of art into the
database and updating the cache. Now we can see that the redirect
the page reload worked and our, and our little tux was in
fact submitted, and we go to our terminal we look at what
happened. We can see the start of our query we've got this,
this little error message from when we looked up the IP from that
feature we had last week. We can see that in our console,
we're printing DB Query in the POST request. This, these log lines aren't
written until after the request is finished. So we're, we're writing tucks
to the database. Then we're reading the database to get the most recent,
the ten most recent items, and then we're redirecting the user,
that's the 302. And then on our next front page request
to get slash, there's no database write. So that means we're
still doing the same number of database reads as we were
doing before with the other solution, except the database read is
triggered on submission, and not on page load. Which has a
really nice property, and that there's no database read for the,
the front page load ever unless the cache is completely empty.